[Música]
como cada 30 de mayo los peruanos
festejan con orgullo el día nacional de
la papa y la mejor manera de hacerle
honor es comiendo el tubérculo en todos
los platos que la imaginación la
gastronomía y el paladar puedan inventar
si nosotros podríamos cambiarlos o
reemplazar el arroz el pan lo estaríamos
haciendo por la papa sabiendo que
tenemos una infinidad de diversidades de
productos y platos que podemos lograr
con este producto victoriano fernández
participa en cada feria que lo invita
para mostrar las distintas variedades de
papa york dolls nos ayudó con tu fue
escarp woofer reclaman kite auquilla
pero en el campo es donde pone su mayor
esfuerzo a través de un ritual de pago a
los ancestros le pide a los espíritus de
los incas que la cosecha sea buena este
campesino es descendiente de una
dinastía de agricultores y es dirigente
de los guardianes de papas nativas y
todavía nosotros pues seguimos
utilizando nos das nuestras herramientas
tradicionales que antiguamente también
nos decían casán utilizaban entonces eso
es el mejor legado que tenemos y eso
creo que es para nosotros es un orgullo
en 19 regiones del perú más de 700 11
mil familias productoras se sostienen
gracias al tubérculo de las 5000
variedades de papas que existen en el
mundo perú posee más de 3500 y es el
primer productor de patata en
latinoamérica algunos expertos como self
y obregón señalan que la papa peruana es
un producto de primera calidad consideró
que cero importación de trigo y cero
importación de maíz no vamos a morir
porque porque la base de nuestra
alimentación está acá sin embargo el
consumo nacional y la exportación de
este año están comprometidos ante la
falta de 180.000 toneladas de
fertilizantes que se debían importar
desde rusia y ucrania para la siembra el
estado peruano invertirá a más de 95
millones de dólares para afrontar la
crisis pero diversos especialistas creen
que no será suficiente el alimento más
importante del perú está en peligro